With
so many facets of modern life being automated,
signatures being easy to forge, and given
how difficult it is to prove based on signature
alone whether a given person actually signed
something, using a person’s exact signature
“design” for verification purposes after
the fact is rapidly going the way of the Dodo.
This leads us to the question of the day-
given all this, is there any rule about what
exactly your signature has to look like?
Can you, for example, just sign all your legal
documents with a big X like they do in cartoons?
As it turns out, just like it’s possible
to cash those big novelty checks because there’s
no rule about what a check has to look like
or be made of (just what information needs
to be included), you can, in many regions
of the world, sign a document in any way you
wish.
This is because a signature from a legal standpoint
is just proof that you considered and accepted
something.
Or to quote the U.S.’ Uniform Commercial
Code §3-401(b):
A signature may be made (i) manually or by
means of a device or machine, and (ii) by
the use of any name, including a trade or
assumed name, or by a word, mark, or symbol
executed or adopted by a person with present
intention to authenticate a writing.
In other words, even if you sign a document
in the U.S. and many other parts of the world
with an ultra-detailed drawing of an anatomically
correct phallus, you’re still legally bound
by the terms of that document because it’s
the act of signing a document that matters,
not the signature itself.
This is why it’s possible to sign documents
using a stamp, pencil, printed signature,
digitally online or even simply by typing
your name at the end of an email message in
which you discuss and state you agree to some
deal.
In fact, there has been a long precedent of
such electronic remote agreements going all
the way back to the telegraph, such as an
1869 case Howley v. Whipple in which a U.S.
court determined that agreeing to terms in
a telegram was indeed legally binding, with
the court stating in part:
When a contract is made by telegraph… if
the parties authorize their agents… to make
a proposition on one side, and the other party
accepts it through the telegraph, that constitutes
a contract in writing under the statue of
frauds… it makes no difference whether [the
telegraph] operator writes with a steel pen
an inch long attached to an ordinary penholder,
or whether his pen be a copper wire a thousand
miles long.
Nor does it make any difference that in one
case common record ink is used, while in the
other case a more subtle fluid, known as electricity,
performs the same office.
Granted, exact rules vary a little from region
to region and some specific institutions might
have internal rules regarding what is an acceptable
signature and what implement must be used
(such as some perhaps requiring something
be signed in blue pen or the like).
But except in very specific cases, in many
regions of the world the law of the land does
not (usually) care in the slightest about
those types of internal rules.
From a legal standpoint, having your signature
be a stamp replica of your dog’s paw print
is a perfectly acceptable way to acknowledge
you agree to the terms of a contract.
Again, the point is just to signify you agree
to the terms.
That said, because of how lax the laws are
with respect to what a signature must look
like (and how difficult it is to determine
if something was signed fraudulently even
when a typical signature is used), certain
contract types require things like witnesses
or sometimes even a notary public to attest
that they observed you signing a document
in order for the statute to be considered
legally valid.
For instance, this is generally the case with
wills or marriage contracts.
(It’s also noteworthy that usually the witnesses
observing the signing of a will also must
not be individuals who are to be bequeathed
something in the will.)
Coming back to the issue of signing something
just using the letter X, you may have deduced
by now that this is very much something you
can usually do outside of specific cases where
a given institution may not accept such.
However, most will accept an X owing to the
fact that this has long been a common way
for illiterate individuals to sign a document.
Other methods sometimes used by those who
can’t write and haven’t otherwise come
up with a scribble signature also include
things like a simple drawing or in some countries
a thumbprint is common.
On this latter thumbprint “signature”
style, while still not bulletproof, this certainly
beats name signatures for later verification
purposes, even for the literate.
Now, with regards to individuals who are illiterate
or otherwise can’t read the language used
in a contract, you may be wondering if they
can really be legally bound by a document
that they can’t even read even if they do
sign it.
It turns out, yes- from a legal standpoint
it is the duty of the signing party to discern
the terms of a contract before signing.
Ignorance about some stipulation in a contract
is not a legal way to get out of it, unless
it can be shown that the other party was deliberately
deceptive about the terms of the contract
or that the contract itself was fundamentally
different than what was expected.
However, this latter point (known as non est
factum) is often an incredibly hard thing
to prove and, again, ignorance of the contents
of the text of a contract is not a valid way
to get the contract voided.
(As you might imagine, this area of contract
law is not without controversy given an illiterate
person may not wish to reveal this fact to
anyone for various reasons including embarrassment,
fear of this fact being exploited, and in
some cases fear a deal will fall through if
their illiteracy was known.)
In any event, beyond the aforementioned misrepresentation
rules, other potential ways a signed contract
may be considered invalid in the eyes of the
law include things like if it was signed under
coercion, if it was voided before the end
of a grace period after signing (for certain
types of contracts), if a person is a minor,
or if the person is deemed mentally impaired
in some significant way.
And, note, being intoxicated or under the
influence of some voluntarily taken substance
does not usually count for getting out of
a contract unless it’s provable that the
other party used said fact to intentionally
exploit the inebriated individual.
So if pretty much anyone can legally sign
a contract in most any way they please outside
of some specific exceptions, just how ridiculous
can your signature get before someone would
notice?
Well, luckily this question was partially
answered by comedian John Hargrave who enjoys
signing checks and receipts as everyone from
Zeus to Mariah Carey without having anyone
question it.
He even for a time attempted to look as shady
as possible in his purchases, including going
on a massive shopping spree, buying a quarter
ton of chemical fertilizer (the stuff you
can use to make a bomb), and signing his receipts
with the word “Stolen”.
In the end, neither his credit card company
nor the cashiers noticed.
This is for somewhat good reason.
For a variety of reasons we’ll get into
in another article later this week, a signature
is an extremely poor data point to use to
determine if a given purchase is fraudulent.
So while credit card companies do record and
otherwise store these signatures electronically,
there’s generally little point in anyone
bothering to actually look at them.
As Mastercard executive Carolyn Balfany notes,
“accessing them is not a regular occurrence”
unless the customer claims they didn’t sign
for or buy something.
But even then, again, the signature is often
only a minor data point used to try to determine
if a given purchase was actually fraudulent.
This laissez-faire attitude these companies
take towards signatures today is a far cry
from several decades ago when they generally
hired huge teams of people to pore over the
signatures, comparing them to the signed cards
on file to ensure something like a check wasn’t
fraudulent before approving the ultimate transfer
of money.
But in modern times, this security measure
(and in a lot of respects a physical signature
alone, even when talking more broadly about
contracts in general) is simply completely
outdated in its effectiveness to achieve the
job it’s intended to do- offer proof you
agreed to something.
In the case of credit cards, even if cashiers
bothered to check signatures at all, which
most don’t, the signature does not provide
any real hurdle to credit card thieves.
(Again, we’ll have more on this in an upcoming
article later this week on why credit card
companies still make you sign the back of
a credit card for said card to be considered
valid, despite this being nearly worthless
as a security measure.)
But to conclude, while certainly a given institution
may have internal requirements with regards
to your signature before they’ll accept
some bit of paperwork or the like as valid,
if you’ve ever had the bright idea to sign
a different name or draw a smiling rocket
powered unicorn with machine guns for teeth
as your signature on a legally binding document
to try to get out of the thing later, don’t
expect this to help you in any legal way.
At the end of the day, it’s the act of signing,
not the physical scribbles you make, that
matters from a legal standpoint.